In this lesson, we'll learn advanced vocabulary with Linkin Park.
You'll watch an interview with the band's late frontman Chester
who opened up about dealing with mental health issues,
and also see examples of the vocabulary
he uses in some of the band's most famous songs.
And remember that every week, we help you learn
real life English just like you see in podcasts, songs and interviews
without getting lost, without missing the jokes and without subtitles,
Just like Tumi who says that ours is
the best channel ever to learn real english.
So if you want to sound more natural
when you speak and less like a robot,
be sure to hit that subscribe button along with the
bell down below so that you don’t miss a single one of our new lessons!
As I mentioned before, here we help
you understand English used in real life.
That's why we created the FwF course
for you to learn whilst having fun.
And the best part is that you can become part of a
community of learners and practice your English right now!
To try it out for FREE, click on the
link up here, or the one in the description below.
If you want to keep improving your
comprehension with real life native conversations,
and also practice your speaking you
should check out the RealLife App we built to help you.
You'll be able to listen to our podcast while
following the transcript and learning all the vocabulary.
On top of that, you can connect to
other English learners from around the world
and practice your speaking while discovering
other cultures in fun and dynamic, short conversations.
The best part is that it is absolutely free!
So download it now by clicking the link down in the description
or simply search for the RealLife English App
in the Apple App Store or Google Play Store.
Download it now and let us guide you beyond the classroom
to live, and learn and speak English in the real world!
If you’re enjoying this lesson, then I
highly recommend you check out this playlist
where you’ll find tons of lessons with
a range of artists and bands.
Just click up here or the link in the
description to check out these lessons!